[Music]
evening everyone happy father's day
welcome to the next revolution i'm steve
hilton and this is the home of positive
populism pro-worker pro-family
pro-community and especially pro-america
there is a big decision
facing republicans in washington next
week and in the weeks ahead
do they cooperate and compromise with
democrats over the two massively
consequential pieces
of legislation they're pushing on
infrastructure and voting
if the democrats if the biden regime
were behaving in line with what they
love to call
democratic norms there would be a strong
case for cooperation and compromise
to get things done for the american
people but get what done
that is the key question and here we can
see
that the democrats are not following
their precious democratic norms in fact
they've thrown them out the window
they're behaving as if biden won by a
landslide
instead of just 44 000 votes in three
states as if they have a majority of 70
in the house instead of five as if they
have 70 senators
instead of 50 that's the truth about
biden and the democrats
this whole regime is built on a lie
to adapt one of their favorite
expressions it is structurally dishonest
you saw it last week biden said the days
of america rolling over to putin are
gone
but then he drops sanctions on putin's
pipeline gives him a platform in
exchange for nothing
and flatters him as a worthy adversary
biden said
he'd be the antidote to the boorish
misogynist trump
and then he yelled at a female reporter
when he didn't like her question
on china biden said he'd replace trump's
go it alone strategy
with concerted action from our allies
instead it was a craven cow tower to
china at the g7
with their limp pathetic communique
biden
tried to lead and no one followed a
total humiliation
at home the dishonesty goes even deeper
biden said he'd heal the wounds of a
divided nation
this is our historic moment of crisis
and challenge
and unity is the path forward we must
end this
uncivil war that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal
well that lasted about five minutes
instead of healing our wounds
he's rubbing salt into them cynically
exploiting racial tensions
to rile up his base with disgusting bad
faith arguments on voting rights
insulting republicans as
un-american jim crow even trashing
republicans on the world stage at nato
the whole point of biden was to be a
moderate
centrist that is not me saying that to
make a political point it's what they
said
in the campaign we have new information
on that from the book
lucky how joe biden barely won the
presidency
i read it so you don't have to quote
there was nothing more politically
valuable to biden than having survived
the democratic primary
as a centrist who had rejected the
increasingly progressive
impulses of his party that was before
the election
after the election on day one pushing
the most extreme elements of
wokism effectively ending girls sports
in his first week
flinging the southern border wide open
in just over a month passing the most
radical expansion of welfare for decades
is any of that rejecting the
increasingly progressive impulses of his
party no it's embracing them
it's the same on race and criminal
justice back during the campaign
in calls after george floyd's death
quote biden's views were represented by
the original set of senior advisers he
wasn't going to tilt left
in the general election after having
maintained a centrist profile
through a brutal primary no he wasn't
going to tilt left
in the general election in case that
cost him votes he'd save the tilting
left until
after the election instead of trying to
forge consensus
on voting reform throwing his full
weight behind pelosi's
partisan effort to rig election rules
and democrats favor with the notorious
hr one
and its banana republic atrocities like
ballot harvesting
he illegally tried to implement a
race-based aid system for farmers
and he pushed racist divisive
anti-american indoctrination in the
federal government with a new lease of
life
a critical race theory and there's more
here's another quote
while trump would try to depress support
for biden by attacking him from both
sides on criminal justice
issues soft on crime and the engineer of
mass incarceration all at once
fair point for biden the eye of the
storm was the safest spot
he's not willing to be on one side or
the other the aide added
what he didn't do is change his platform
on criminal justice nothing changed from
day one to where he ended up
said a top campaign official but where
did he end up
after the election siding with far left
activists pushing not police reform but
police retreat
launching bureaucratic witch hunts
targeting entire forces
contributing to the disrespect of the
police that's making officers
demoralized
and cities more dangerous on and on it
goes the evidence of biden's structural
dishonesty listen to this quote
biden's centrism created friction with
efforts to unify a democratic party that
didn't fully agree with him on policy
yeah and we know how they resolved that
friction they just caved
to the far left instead of leading
getting them to agree to his view
biden surrendered and signed up to their
agenda
nationalizing child care just like
elizabeth warren wanted
cancelling student loan debt just like
bernie wanted climate extremism just
like aoc wanted
even on the pandemic caving to the
left's long-running lunatic campaign
to cancel patterns the very thing that
helped us get the vaccines in record
time
all of it adding up to the biggest
expansion of government in american
peacetime history
it is a brazen bid to turn america
into a european-style welfare state
with the giant bureaucracy and high
taxes to pay for it
where was all that in anything biden
said in the election
he has no mandate for any of this he
barely has a mandate for moderate
leftism
let alone this extremism we're seeing
there was no biden landslide just 51
in the popular vote tied in the senate
only just ahead in the house defeated
right across the country at the state
level if he had a mandate
it was to calm the country down
restoring the soul of america he's not
even trying to do that he's doing the
opposite
stoking hate and division far from
restoring the soul of america biden's in
the process of ripping it out
and replacing it with the soulless
technocratic nightmare of a centralized
federal government
monster rampaging over the rights and
values and principles laid out in the
constitution
and the dishonesty continues biden
claims now
falsely he's still the same old joe
peck columnists dutifully lapped it up
including this
laughable assessment from david brooks
in the new york times
biden hasn't changed he's just gone
bigger
let's remember that the next time
there's a republican in the white house
and the media hyperventilate about right
wing extremism
it's not right wing it's just bigger
well i suppose in one respect
biden really hasn't changed he is still
a pathetic
weak machine politician who believes in
nothing
except his own personal advancement from
another book
we knew already he wanted to be
president since his
twenties not to do anything in
particular
just to be the president as a result
biden is the puppet
of his donors and the prisoner of the
power centers in his party and right now
that is the woke left
and the government unions he ran as a
moderate but he's ruling as a radical
this regime is structurally dishonest
in fact of all the things biden said to
get elected there's basically only one
where he was truthful i would in fact
make sure
that there is we immediately surge to
the border
all those people are seeking asylum
yeah the one moment of truth a
preview of the disaster biden has
already created now we await
the disasters to come from his far left
agenda that no one wants let alone voted
for
80 percent of your party says it's
center left no i am saying
farther left is getting more attention
it's getting amplified
look there's a disconnect look it's
center left
that's where i am they're looking for
somebody who in fact
can articulate what they believe and
it's within the mainstream remember
they're not all
and i'm this is not a hit on burning my
word
but they're but these this is not a
generation of socialist
you know me you know my heart
you know my story my family story ask
yourself
do i look like a radical socialist
you're sure acting like one people made
the mistake
of believing biden when he said he was a
moderate in fact
he was a nothing just a trojan horse for
the ideas of bernie sanders and
elizabeth warren
if you add up all the votes in all the
primaries bernie got 27
and warren got eight it's a minority of
even the democratic party
and now it's being foisted on the whole
country so no
when this dishonest regime when this
structurally dishonest
systemically dishonest regime comes to
republicans in the weeks ahead
looking for cooperation and compromise
the answer must be
to respect the will of the voters who
comprehensively rejected
the far left ideas that biden is now
pushing follow us at steve hilton x and
at nextrev fnc
and share this message when we post it
try and convince those republicans
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else